leute bevor das video losgeht weil ich
kurz sagen es wird im video sehr
mathematisch deswegen wenn ihr darauf
generell kein bock habt schaut sich erst
gar nicht an
aber wir haben in schönenwerd am ende
raus bekommen und mich freuen wenn ihr
das video ganz haut und weil es noch
sagen wollte aber hier auf jeden fall
den kanal wir sehen jetzt schon bei 3
30% vor allen leuten die meine videos
schauen habe ich auch abonniert mal
gucken wie wir das noch nach oben geht
und jetzt viel spaß
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch und
heute gehen wir mal ein paar sachen auf
die schliche und zwar regen sicher sehr
viele leute man darüber auf dass
youtuber so viel geld verdient wobei
natürlich die einen mehr verdienen die
einen weniger kommen wir auf die
morgenshow ankommt auf die reichweite
ankommt auf das marketing an und so
weiter und ich weiß nicht ob viele von
euch noch snapshot benutzen ich schon
und in meinem fall werden wir immer so
beiträge vorgeschlagen oder so artikel
von irgendwelchen seiten und da ist
wirklich der größte quatsch dabei und
mir wurde ein artikel vorgeschlagen der
nennt sich insider verrät so viel
verdienen youtuber wirklich mit ihren
videos von einem gewissen romy stiegler
oder einer gewissen romy stiegler und
ich habe mir diesen artikel durchgelesen
und konnte wirklich nur den kopf
schütteln ich hab mir gedacht da kann
man sehr gut ein video machen und danach
würde ich ganz gerne mal selber richten
und jetzt beispielfall jetzt baby und
danke an
also ich würde dann einfach nach diesem
artikel selber mal kurz rechnen dass die
dann so verdienen so also hier haben wir
den artikel wie schon eben gesagt
insider verrät so viel verdienen
youtuber wirklich mit ihren video
influenza wie beispielsweise einem
youtuber sein das ist der wunsch vieler
junger menschen
doch wie viel verdient man eigentlich
mit diesem job das hat nun ein
erfolgreicher youtuber verraten wo baby
einige dhabi und co die liste der
erfolgreichsten youtube mittlerweile bin
ich mal gespannt was ist denn die liste
der erfolgreichsten youtube
wollt ihr mich verarschen erfolgreich
ist hier mit so einem link markiert und
man kommt wegen der versicherung ist
mittlerweile tatsächlich relativ lange
kein wunder dass viele junge menschen
junge menschen denn junge menschen den
wunsch hegen eines tages auch einmal
influenza wie blogger oder eben youtuber
zu werden diese frage beantwortet nun
einer von ihnen selbst nie publique et
nico pliquett seines zeichens
erfolgreicher auf youtube
ich kenne ihn sogar habe ich mir auch
schon mal ein video von angeschaut blau
dass der laut bravo de aus dem
nähkästchen erst vor allem jahr stieg er
ins youtube ist uns ein und dreht seit
der film über autos mittlerweile hat er
mehr als 92.000 abonnenten insgesamt 15
millionen aufrufe hat der hamburger weil
sie den clip zu kommen und das rechnet
sich laut nico ganz schön sagte 19.000
euro an wert damit verdienen beide das
ist ja hier macht auto videos und er hat
halt insgesamt 15.000.000 news generiert
19.000 euro damit verdient also sprich
ungefähr pro 1000 klicks 1 euro 10 euro
15 21 kein plan wer nun denkt das sei
viel youtube star demi hat mit ihren
videos bereits ganz 900 millionen klicks
gesammelt nikos aussage zufolge bedeutet
das eine million klicks machen 1266 euro
zehn millionen klicks ergeben zehnfache
12.600 60 euro und 100 millionen klicks
bedeuten 126 1666 euro für den
jeweiligen user das würde bedeuten dass
da die mit ihren clubs bereits
unglaubliche 11 39 also über 11
millionen euro verdient hat das ding ist
das sind natürlich zahlen die vielleicht
so ein bisschen in die richtige richtung
gehen allerdings nicht der realität
entsprechen also er kann ja nicht sagen
wobei ich hier auch sagen muss
ob das jetzt wirklich jeder nico gesagt
hat dass da die 1,8 mal was haben wir
hier also nur weil der nico für eine
million klicks 1266 euro bekommt heißt
es ja nicht dass da wieder auf 1266 euro
mehr bekommt ich zum beispiel auch nicht
bei mir ist es sogar mehr und ich kann
bei solchen artikeln wirklich nur mit
dem kopf schütteln weil es halt
irgendeinen redakteur ist der absolut
gar keine ahnung davon hat das ding ist
dann sehen eine million snapshot user
weiter hoch und lesen sich das durch und
dann babys videos von babys beauty
palace haben bereits über vier millionen
klicks abgesahnt
das würde bedeuten sie hätte dafür 5000
euro kassiert und auch babys videos von
lewis beauty palace der satz ist erstens
total schwer zu lesen
und zweitens macht ja keinen sinn weil
wir ja schon weitaus über eine
milliarden klicks gemacht hat und darauf
was beziehen die sich jetzt hier doch
achtung nicht alle youtuber verdienen
gleich es kommt ganz drauf an welche
werbeverträge sie jeweils abgeschlossen
haben außerdem verdienen sich viele auch
mit eigenen produkten etwas dazu wie
etwa baby mit ihrem du schauen
hinzu kämen noch hohe ausgaben für gutes
equipment wie nico bravo.de sagte für
eine gute videoqualität braucht man
schließlich gute kameras noch kann der
autofans nicht ausschließlich von
youtube-clips leben aber babys und tages
rechnung haben definitiv gezeigt dass
das geht ja mein baby mit vier millionen
klicks schon 5000 euro kassiert da habe
ich auf jeden fall für den rest ihres
lebens ausgesorgt hat wie ich ja eben
schon gesagt habe ich glaube nicht dass
der nico wirklich im hingegangen ist und
gesagt hat ja pass auf da die verdienen
so und so viel meine richtung ja ich
glaube das ist halt wirklich einfach
total dumm schlecht recherchiert worden
von diesem redakteur hier oder dieser
redakteurin auch dieser satz hinzu käme
noch hohe ausgaben für gutes equipment
wie nico bravo.de sagt gut wenn man
jetzt 19.000 euro mit seinen videos
bisher verdient hat und gutes equipment
braucht sagen wir einfach mal fünf bis
zehntausend euro kann man das natürlich
sagen aber dass jetzt so verallgemeinert
hinzustellen als würde da die extrem
hohe ausgaben für equipment haben das
ist vielleicht ein prozent von dem was
sie im monat verdient also wenn ihr
irgendwo artikel angezeigt bekommt lest
ihr am besten gar nicht das ist immer
der größte quatsch wir rechnen jetzt mal
anhand von dagegen die eine sache wollte
ich noch sagen ich gerade auch extrem
lustig fand und zwar hier einfach stumpf
gesagt für 900 millionen klicks bekommt
man ja insgesamt 1,1 millionen euro das
ding ist nur dann gemacht youtube seit
sie nicht sieben jahren oder so und
früher wo sie angefangen hat konnte man
glaube ich noch gar kein geld verdienen
als ich damals angefangen habe konnte
man auch noch kein geld verdienen und
ich mache das jetzt seit gut fünf jahren
habe ich mal mein erstes video
hochgeladen oder so seit vier jahren
macht channel aktiv und die einnahmen
früher lagen halt ganz deutlich unter
dem was man jetzt bekommt bei mir
zumindest okay ich habe jetzt gerade
doch die wir ausgesucht weil mich das
selber eigentlich
mehr interessiert ist die größte youtube
und ja wir rechnen uns einfach mal baby
macht videos die sind alle über zehn
minuten wenn man bei mir ist in die
analytik schauen würde was ich glaube
ich nicht machen da ich generiere so für
1000 klicks ungefähr zwei dollar also
bisschen weniger in euro umgerechnet
wobei ich auch sagen muss dass vieles
von meinem content als ziemlich derbe
freundlich eingestuft wird dass es
sollte aber bei baby ungefähr genauso
sein da sie jetzt aber jedes video war
zehn minuten macht ich nicht da kann sie
noch einmal mehr werbung schalten würde
ich das jetzt einfach sagen
die beam kriegt zwei dollar 50 im
durchschnitt ich krieg zwei dollar wenn
man das jetzt umrechnet sind zwei euro
und das ist wirklich eine zahl die
meiner meinung nach ziemlich der
realität entsprechen sollte falls nicht
würde ich mich selber sehr sehr sehr
wundern wenn es jetzt deutlich darüber
liegen würde oder halt deutlich drunter
es wurde ich immer meinen taschenrechner
so bibi hat in den letzten 30 tagen 35
millionen views gemacht wir rechnen
jetzt einfach mal für einen monat was
verdienen baby im monat für mich gerade
auf ein bisschen schlechter ist jetzt
versuche so offen zu legen oder
irgendwie berechnen will aber es gibt ja
diese dummen seiten die das versuchen
und damit halt leser generieren deswegen
wir stellen das jetzt einigermaßen
richtig wofür tausend klicks haben wir
gerade gesagt willkommen baby zwei euro
18 das heißt für eine million klicks 2
eur 18.000 2180 euro für eine million
klicks mal 35,5 gleich 77 1390 euro wie
die seite aber auch schon klar gesagt
hat es kommt darauf an welche
werbeverträge sie jeweils abgeschlossen
haben außerdem verdienen sie viel mit
eigenen produkten und ich würde sogar
sagen weiß natürlich nicht was baby von
dem wirklich bekommt aber das ist ja
wirklich ein sehr sehr sehr
erfolgreiches produkt das ist eine zahl
die liegt sicherlich pro monat zwischen
50 und über 100.000 ich kann das jetzt
wirklich gar nicht einschätzen ich würde
sagen wir recht und da einfach mal mit
dem geringsten 50.000 würde ich so sagen
nur für die bierflaschen weil es gibt ja
sogar mütter die sowas benutzen also das
ist wirklich ein gutes produkt das hat
sich gut im markt etabliert natürlich
ist es bei solchen sachen dann immer die
frage was wirklich dann beim
eigentlichen künstler bei rumkommt weil
natürlich auch unternehmen zwischen
stecken die wollen ja auch was davon
haben vielleicht bekommen wir wieder
auch einen festen satz pro monat
man weiß es nicht so optimal hat weiß
ich gerade gar nicht aber vor sich hat
sogar insgesamt schon zwei milliarden
news gemacht hat so jetzt hab ich hier
gar nicht gerecht und also wir sind
jetzt gerade bei 127 1390 euro brutto
also ohne steuern irgendwie sehe ich
keinen merge ich kann mich zwar daran
erinnern dass ich schon mal leute
gesehen hat mit videos beauty palace
sachen anscheinend gibt es die aber gar
nicht mehr deswegen können wir merkt
schon mal außen vor lassen was dann
jetzt aber nochmal hinzukommt werden das
heißt irgendein unternehmen sagt hey
mach doch mal einem video für uns was
willst du dafür haben bei einer
reichweite von 1,3 millionen ich würde
mal sagen sie dazu eine millionen
garantierte views pro video müsste sogar
eigentlich ein bisschen darüber liegen
sagen wir einfach mal 1,5 millionen man
rechnet ungefähr mit 80 euro pro 1000
klicks das war immer so eine faustformel
die mir auch früher einmal gesagt wurde
und das kann ich auch bis jetzt immer
sagen das ist ungefähr der realität
entspricht das heißt wir haben 80 euro
für 1000 klicks tausend mal 1500 wert 15
millionen das heißt wir rechnen 80 x
1500 gleich 120000 sollte wie mindestens
für eine produktion bekommen damit ja
dann meistens auch noch münster post mit
vereinbart und so weiter als es sollte
sogar ein bisschen über diesen 120000
liegen hat sich wahrscheinlich gerade
extrem viel an aber das ist halt einfach
die realität sagen wir jetzt einfach mal
120.000 mindestens das heißt wenn wir
den ganz normalen monat hat mit
youtube-videos einer produktplatzierung
und noch blue kommen wir bei 2 bei einer
4 millionen euro raus brutto das wird
sicherlich manchmal darüber liegen
manchmal wird es drunter liegen genau
sagen kann man es nicht aber das ist ein
wert mit dem man umgehen kann meiner
meinung nach wenn ihr euch jetzt auch
ausgehen aber so könnt ihr keine kritik
in die kommentare schreiben ob irgendwas
falsch gerechnet habe oder so natürlich
kommen bestimmt noch kleine andere
sachen vielleicht sind damit ein
aber wir haben hier halt 247.000 raum
hat 90 euro für einen monat ganz wichtig
das ist ein bruttowert sie wäre damit
auch im höchsten in der höchsten
steuerklasse in deutschland und müsste
fast die hälfte nochmal an steuern
wieder abgeben also hat sie dann im
endeffekt 130000 euro von den 4000 euro
die ihr über bleiben netto habe ich das
gute rechnet oder gut gerechnet
ach so ja heute mathestunde mit alex ist
für heute vorbei ich habe selber ein
bisschen meinen kopf trainiert warum
allerdings video
ich hoffe es hat euch unterhalten und
die content folgen falls nicht tut mir
leid aber ich denke schon ich habe mein
bestes gegeben wir sehen uns morgen
wieder da gibt's ja wieder ein normales
video eigentlich besteht ja main kanal
nicht aus so was aus irgendwelchen
sachen vorrechnen aber ich musste
einfach aufgrund dieses artikels dieses
video machen weil ich das schon wieder
so dumm fand und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder boni nicht vergessen wird mich
sehr darüber freuen über ein abo von
euch rein
ciao